[Music]
there's never a dull moment at
Glenfinnan house mana and Duncan Gibson
have run the hotel for 15 years now they
take care of the guests in the kitchen
under their management the hotel has won
a host of accolades Glenfinnan house
lies on picturesque Loch Shiel it's a
country mansion built in the 18th
century here in Scotland's West
Highlands tourism is a seasonal trade
though the summer months are always busy
but local businesses have also had a bit
of good luck with films like Harry
Potter it's just been phenomenal
especially in the low harbour area
because they filmed a lot of the Harry
Potter movies in the area we've had the
film team staying here many times as
well that's because just a stone's throw
away from the hotel Harry Potter's train
crosses the world-famous Glenfinnan
viaduct every day before Harry Potter's
time Glenfinnan and the surrounding area
was just a remote region on Scotland's
west coast now it's a tourist magnet but
brexit could change all that because
workers from other EU countries may no
longer be welcome here
I think the des viscous that we don't
have enough workers in the area to cover
the summer months and all the
restaurants and hotels because we really
struggle with try to work with the local
Jobcentre to find workers locally and
we've just found it impossible if
Britain forces EU nationals to leave
manya would be personally affected too
although she's lived in the UK for
nearly 20 years she's German the
children via kind of worried when they
heard the bird Prix it especially the
youngest one and she was like oh no mom
you have to leave now and I said I don't
think it's cool like this but you know
it's it's a big talking point you know
in the family and within the school you
know and normal family life
in spring the west coast of Scotland
looks like something out of the
storybook with its rolling hills
flowering gorse and tranquil days in the
high season the Train steams by
Glenfinnan twice a day it winds its way
through the highlands then runs along
the coast the tiny fishing village of my
leg is the end of the line some 15,000
tourists flock here every month for
residents of this remote region it's a
bit of magic worthy of Harry Potter
himself I don't think that trend is very
important to the fishing village of
mullick bringing the number of people
that we do everyday through the season
without the Train there's just the one
rod into my leg so of the the businesses
here suffer Malik's fishing industry is
in decline so locals operate hotels
restaurants and cafes instead the region
relies heavily on tourism over 200,000
jobs depends on it
Duncan Gibson is in the kitchen whipping
up some fine Scottish cuisine the
award-winning chef makes a trip to
Glenfinnan house a culinary treat to the
restaurant is popular its waitstaff come
from Bulgaria Hungary and Lithuania
this is Monica's first season here but
she's been to Britain often when I came
here this time it was something
different in airports they asked me a
few questions and like why I came here
Constantine is another of the ten
non-british EU nationals working at
Glenfinnan House last year he was a
bartender now he's working his way up to
Deputy Hotel Manager he thinks Britain
needs workers like him if that happens
with all the real workers here at the
same time I think there's gonna be
rebellion or something cause I don't
think that the British economy can exist
without the you or cassia they don't
have the people to sustain the economy
Manya says without workers from the
continent they might as well close down
what about her personally well I could
apply for quitter citizenship as well I
kind of hope I don't have to kind of
hope everything will still be in place
and that things on laws are put in place
for European citizens living here on a
permanent basis and have been living
here for a long time as well
outside Glenfinnan receives a visit from
a stranger who needn't worry about being
asked to leave Manya Gibson and her
staff hope things will turn out all
right for them in the end
but since britain voted to exit the EU
they face an uncertain future